grab your time machine and your German
English dictionary's I'm gonna translate
the German instructions for you because
we have the most difficult family trees
since the royal family yes dark season 2
expands on the already complicated
season 1 with new timelines revelations
and incest we'll get to that in a bit
but don't get your lederhosen in a twist
because think story is here to solve
some of your most unanswered questions
about the season as well as what's in
store for season 3 the episode begins in
what can only be assumed is the year
2050 3 it's never explicitly said that
this is the year but knowing that the
apocalypse happened in 2020 and that the
difference between each time period is
33 years this is as close as we'll get
to the answer 33 years may seem like a
random period of time but it's explained
in season 1 that this is due to the
solar and lunar cycles aligning once in
that period of time we see who will
later discover is the adult version of
Elisabeth Doppler who we know survived
the apocalypse in the bunker along with
Claudia Regina
Peter and Noah and the huge revelation
here is that Noah is her lover and they
had a child a child who will later grow
up to become Charlotte Doppler but how
is that possible Elisabeth is
Charlotte's daughter
we know that Charlotte was adopted and
never knew her mother or father were in
episode 5 of this season Noah reveals
himself to be her father
but doesn't give away who her mother is
for obvious reasons because imagine
finding out your daughter is your mom
that's at the end of the season we see
young Noah enter the bunker with
Elizabeth and since they'll spend the
apocalypse together and we know that
Noah will be going back and forth
through time it's easy to assume that
Noah and Elizabeth will have a
relationship and in order to save their
daughter he'll take her to the year 1953
to grow up where she'll eventually have
Elizabeth and this cycle will continue
over and over again
this also explains in season 1 when
Elizabeth tells her parents she met a
man in the forest named Noah who gives
her a pocket watch a watch with the
inscription for Charlotte it's a weird
token of the child they'll someday have
together but why is it that older
Elizabeth kills anyone who enters the
dead zone the only bit of info we get is
when
she confronts her interpreter and tells
her that other people think this portal
is a piece of God but it's actually a
piece of the devil she wants to keep
people away from it and now that we know
there's a connection between her Noah
her daughter and secundus the true
meaning behind this will likely play out
in season 3 so we'll have to put a pin
in it for now old Noah talks to young
Noah about his fate how he purposely
kept things from him because that's what
turned him into the man he is today what
the - Noah's don't know yet is that Adam
was simply using them as pawns and that
later in this episode he'll kill old
Noah we also learned that one of Adam's
henchmen is Magnus Nielsen he's next to
a girl who I assume is the grown-up
Francesca dopler even though it's never
explicitly said who she is
but since Magnus and Francesca end up
going back in time together and are in
love I think it's a safe assumption this
also leads to another theory for season
3 at the end of the episode Bartos
Magnus old Jonas and Francesca used the
time machine to travel to an unknown
time right before the apocalypse my
guess is that the events in season 3
will force these characters to choose
between siding with SiC Mundus or the
white devil the white devil being
Claudia and her cohort we never see an
old version of Bartos so my guess is
that he either dies or switches
allegiances especially since he now
knows Noah who is part of SiC Mundus was
merely using him as a pawn this whole
time it's also important to discuss the
differences between SiC linda's and the
white devil SiC Mundus is a group of
time travelers headed by Adam who's an
extremely old and scarred version of
Jonas Khan wolde he likely changed his
name to Adam as an Amash to gods first
male Adam from the Adam and Eve story
Adam says there's a constant battle
between good and evil
light and shadow and that he is the
light he tells Jonas that secundus has
declared war against God God just being
another word for time and since time is
merciless it must be stopped Claudia on
the other hand believes she can change
things that unlike Adam we aren't
chained to fate
she tells Jonas that a small part of the
equation can be changed so that the next
time he attempts to close the loop it'll
be for good if you remembered
as previously attempted to close the
loop but all he ended up doing was
blocking the passage between the
different times within the cave this
meant from then on that the only way to
travel between times was either through
the god particle or a time machine
Bartos has a heart-to-heart with his
mother Regina who is dying from
late-stage breast cancer he tells her
that Claudia came last fall and told him
she's sorry and wished she could turn
back time claudia was the most attentive
mother to regina and criticized her for
her messy appearance in season one not
to mention she killed her own father
Aegon Tiedemann so she is a lot she
wishes she could take back I also think
it's crazy ironic that the woman who
used to run a power plant has both her
father and daughter diagnosed with
cancer nuclear power and radiation being
commonly associated with cancer Claussen
the head of the special task force in
charge of finding the missing children
in windin brings in alexander Tiedemann
who he has discovered is actually a
wanted felon named Boris nee Wald a man
on the run since 1986 who was
responsible for killing his brother
Alexander Koehler when Boris assumed
this new identity as Alexander he later
would marry Regina Tiedemann and in an
effort to further entrench himself in
this new identity took her last name
it's only when Claussen receives an
anonymous letter from a quote friend
telling him the answers regarding his
murdered brother can be found in windin
that he volunteers to become the lead in
this special task force we never find
out who wrote him that letter but my
guess is that this was all part of
Claudia's plan because if Claussen ever
found out Alexander's true identity he
would never get the warrant for the
power plant that leads up to digging up
the concrete and the eventual creation
of the portal older Jonas tries to
convince Martha to come with him and
when she refuses he pulls Hannah's gun
on her saying I've seen you die once I
won't have it happen again
now this is really interesting because
he could be referring to one of two
things here one her grave which he sees
in the future or two the fact that she's
shot by Adam at the end of the episode
which younger Jonas hasn't lived through
yet Katarina Nielsen finds Jonases bag
which contains maps of the cave system
she'll leave the time machine at home
which old Jonas will later pick up and
use before venturing into the caves
which she believes may
old clues to where her missing son
Mikkel and husband Ulrich vanished but
it'll be interesting to see which time
period she ends up in 1987 where Mikkel
is being looked after by nurse
eNOS or 1954 where Ulrich is behind bars
for the murders of the children found in
the field where the nuclear power plant
was going to be built the events at the
end of the episode reopened the loop
allowing Katarina to survive the
apocalyptic blast so it'll be
interesting to see where her storyline
goes next season
speaking of Katarina before she goes off
to the caves she has a talk to Jonas who
lays the foundation for season 3 he's
learned that he can't change the past
which he tried to do by preventing his
father from committing suicide he was
told by Adam if he can stop that he can
prevent everything but this was all a
lie by Adam so Jonases new plan is to
stop himself from becoming Adam Noah
confronts Adam about his real intentions
that he never was waging a war against
god but against humanity he tries to
shoot Adam but it doesn't work Adam says
that it's not part of his fate but if
you'll notice later he just didn't have
the safety on but more shocking is his
death at the hands of his sister Agnes
but why would his sister kill him other
than him turning against SiC Mundus well
there's a theory that Agnes and Noah
were once married or at least lovers in
season 1 we know that Agnes was once
married to a pastor and if she found out
about Noah's eventual love affair with
Elizabeth it just might be that spark
that makes her want to kill him expect
more details about the Agnes Noah
Elizabeth love triangle in season 3 it's
at this time we also see young Noah
venture out from the church unaware that
he'll be killed at the hands of Adam and
his sister ready to continue this cycle
over again before setting up the time
machine
Jonas tells Claudia that he's been
training for a year with older Claudia
learning how everything works the past
and the future
he reopens the loop which causes the
lights to flicker and birds to drop from
the sky we've seen dead birds in season
1 along with dozens of dead cattle
according to the pathologist part of
this is caused by ruptured eardrums as a
result of the loop being open and shot
meanwhile older Jonas is visited by
young della and there are
few interesting things which are all set
up for season three Noah tells Jonas
that they'll go on to become good
friends before Jonas betrays him he's
also handed a letter from Martha but we
never see what's on it
but my theory is that it has something
to do with future Martha who we'll get
to in a bit perhaps a clue that
something in this future loop has
changed Noah tells Jonas he must save
Bartos francesca and magnus and later
agnes in him this all points to events
we'll see in season three he tells them
the loop must be closed so the next
cycle can begin in order that Martha
will survive Martha finds young Jonas
but they're interrupted by Adam who
tells him that he must continue the loop
because the dark matter which is created
in 2020 as a result of the apocalypse
will be needed my Adam to create a new
future the end of the world
he shoots Martha because he says it will
be the trigger that makes him into the
man he will one day become aka Adam now
Jonas must choose between saving Martha
or going after Adam to stop him and I
think it's clear which one he chooses
Jonas convinces Magnus francesca and
Bartos to take the time machine with him
saving them from the apocalypse while
Claussen uncovers the radioactive
material which seems to be covered in
what my best guess is cesium the
material that's needed to fuel the time
machine but this time there's a [ __ ] ton
of it katerina follows the signal which
ends up being these flowing particles
which Jonas mentioned is the flow of
time Charlotte meets her mother daughter
through the opening of the portal and
just as the apocalypse is about to
happen the camera seemingly sucks
Charlotte into the portal so my guess
for season three is that Charlotte will
have survived the blast and will be
transported to the future will or learn
a bit more about how this whole
mother-daughter thing works in the end
almost all our characters have found
some way to survive the apocalyptic
blast whether it be by Time Machine the
cave bunker the portal or super super
Time Machine yes the biggest cliffhanger
of this season is the arrival of Martha
- who has some new type of device if you
remember back in episode 5 of this
season Adam says that quote each
development builds on the other so in
each cycle some new discovery is made we
have the bunker then the time machine
and the
the nuclear power plant my guess is that
this device is the new development but
instead of traveling through time it can
also travel through dimensions aka space
where multiple worlds can exist when
Joan asked Martha what time she's from
she answers the question isn't what time
but what world so if you thought this
show couldn't get more confusing it
looks like will not only be
incorporating different times next
season but different worlds but will be
interesting here is if the seemingly
lifeless body of Martha will be brought
with them to this new world or if
something new entirely will happen
there's also the question of where or
when Adam is he stepped through his own
portal in 1921 in a radiation suit so
it's possible it could be the future but
Adam also told Jonas that this machine
can be worked so that you can travel to
a specific point in time not just 33
years in the future or past I wouldn't
be surprised if that comes into play
next season to recap where our
characters left off in preparation for
season 3 we have older Jonas Magnus
francesca and Bartos who take the time
machine to an unknown time Charlotte who
was likely sucked into the future to be
with Elizabeth Katarina in the cave who
will either step out in 1954 or 1987
Peter
Elizabeth young Noah Claudia and Regina
who are in the bunker and young Jonas
and Martha - who could be almost
anywhere I could probably end up doing
an hour-long video on each individual
episode this particular video I just
wanted to cover the big points of the
final episode so if you still have
lingering questions please make sure to
comment below leave a like and subscribe
because I have more videos on the way
you can follow me on Twitter at think
story whitey and remember daddy loves
you very much